alright hey everyone and welcome back
today we have Jace with us and we're
here to talk about the community
diversity and inclusion efforts and how
Google is giving back Jace why don't you
cheers yourself thanks Seth so I'm Jason
singer Dumars I work in cloud native
strategy and I work for Saren Avani who
is one of the seminal members of the
communities community who helped create
what we think of as a kubernetes
community now so a lot of those things
so basically I spend every day learning
about all the amazing things she does
and so that's where I start from is that
that spot so awesome so aside from Sara
what's your favorite part about the
kubernetes community what I have heard
from a lot of people is that this is one
of the best open source communities to
come in as a complete beginner even to
coding or to community itself and to
feel like you have a home that people
care about what your progression in the
community and all the things that you
care about as well what are some things
that kubernetes is doing to help advance
a quality you know help expand diversity
and make sure that it's an inclusive
environment well this year we
bootstrapped the crew Nettie's code of
conduct committee so we actually have a
group of five people who are focused on
making sure that those things are
evident across the community as well as
having really strong policies and
processes in place around that so that's
really great I'm one of the five people
Paris Putnam and from Google is also on
there so that's great we have Google
representation on that awesome it sounds
like there's a lot of Google
representation and you know kubernetes
is obviously on the technical side but
also from the community side as well
what are some other ways in which Google
is getting involved in helping out well
we help the mentorship program move
forward so that is a great entry point
for a lot of people who want to get
involved in the community and that again
Parris Pittman is a dynamo she does so
much work for the contributor experience
special interest group and basically we
are constantly seeking out opportunities
where we can widen the net and bring
more people into the community
awesome so one last question sure if you
could share one piece of advice to
someone new to the community maybe it's
a student or maybe it's someone who's
been in the industry for 50 years what
one thing that you would say to them I'd
say that don't be afraid to talk to
anybody in the project if somebody has
seen as a luminary like you know Tim
Hawkins or Brian grant or the thought
leaders they're completely approachable
and everybody in the project is the same
way so if you have a question it doesn't
matter who it is this is a community
where you could ask it and get an answer
in a good way
awesome thank you very much Jase my
pleasure set things
[Music]